vous voulez acheter un produit en
reconditionné que ce soit un smartphone
un ordinateur une tablette et pourquoi
pas une mononde connecté mais comment
être sûr que les produits soni
reconditionnés correctement comment être
sûr qu'ils sont sérieux et comment être
sûr que c'est pas une arnaque pour
répondre à cette question je vous emmène
aujourd'hui chez un reconditionneur
français Smart avec 3A qui nous ouvre
ses portes pour découvrir le process les
principes du reconditionnement vous
allez voir c'est extrêmement intéressant
et pour acheter vos produits
reconditionné dans les meilleures
conditions Smart vous offre 15 € dès 200
€ d'achat profitez-en je vous mets le
lien juste en dans la description
cliquez vous allez pas le regretter on
part chez Smart quasiment au pied du pic
saint-lou à quelques minutes de
Montpellier à saint-matieu de Trévier
vous allez découvrir cette entreprise
pas comme les autres salut Nicolas
bonjour Alors moi je voudrais que tu
m'expliques quand les produits arrivent
chez Smart comment s'assurer déjà que ce
sont des produits qui ont pas été volé
comment est-ce que vous pouvez vous vous
assurer de ça et qu'est-ce qui va être
de de mes données les données du client
qui Arve par exemple comment être sûr
qu'elles sont totalement remise à zéro
c'est une question qui est hyper
importante c'est même le cœur de notre
métier on commence directement par
effacer les données c'est la première
chose qu'on fait de manière à garantir
déjà à nos fournisseurs et à nos futurs
clients que les produits sont
parfaitement clean il y a plus rien
dessus ça nous permet aussi de bien
tester les produits parce qu'ils sont
dans un état propre impeccable donc
effacer les données nous on utilise des
outils du marché qui nous fournissent
des certificats d'effacement et qui
permett justement de d'être certain que
ça fonctionne est-ce que vous arrivez à
vérifier les les numéros IMEI je prends
notamment sur sur un smartphone sur un
PC un Mac un numéro de série est-ce que
vous croisez les données par rapport au
au banques de données de la police oui
il y a plusieurs bases de données il y a
notamment des grandes bases de données
mondiales qui permettent de blacklister
qui permettent de faire un blacklist
d'interdire le smartphone on ne permet
pas une fois blacklisté de de rejoindre
le réseau téléphonique ok génial merci
Nicolas première partie les produits
arrivés ici chez Smart ils sont déballés
avant d'être vérifiés la première chose
qui va se passer ici il y a sol derrière
qui est en train de faire un test
fonctionnel pour vérifier que la machine
est totalement opérationnelle sur
tablette et smartphone c'est exactement
le même principe on vient effacer ici
voyez derrière on est en train d'effacer
des tablettes différentes tablettes de
Samsung qui sont en train d'être remises
à zéro comme ça on est sûr une fois de
plus que aucune donnée ne restera dans
la machine alors toi Kevin tu fais des
tests pour t'assurer que le smartphone
est fonctionnel c'est ça j'ai tout un
panel de test à faire donc l'application
me guide pour savoir vraiment de quoi
faire là par exemple pour le tactile je
dois suivre toute une LG comme ça
d'accord là ça le ça le valide après là
j'ai ici pour voir s'il y a pas des des
tâes sur le LCD donc j'ai différentes
couleurs voilà pour voir les points
lumineux aussi et là tout va bien là
tout va bien ça m'a l'air correct et
donc là je vois que tu as plein de
choses charge sans fil caméra flash face
ID face avant donc ça en fait tuas un
process que tu suis c'est ça smartphone
par smartphone pour être sûr que tout
fonctionne ok génial merci Kevin avec
plaisir quand vous achetez votre
smartphone il y a un état état moyen
excellent état bref il a des états sauf
que votre smartphone avant même queon
retrouve sur le site lorsqu'il arrive
ici chez Smart et bien il faut venir lui
donner un état de base pour savoir quel
est son état et son état ici que c'est
qu'il donne c'est loï salut loï et salut
alors loï moi je veux savoir quand un
smartphone arrive chez Smart avant même
qu'il soit réparé avant même qu'il soit
nettoyé comment ça se passe comment
est-ce que toi tu viens lui donner une
note je relève tous les défauts sur les
appareils quand on le reçoit donc on
donne un petit coup de nettoyage pour
éviter de confondre des rayures avec des
salissures et après ben je regarde
chaque face et je relève les plus gros
défauts constatés donc là tu VO quoi sur
cel il a des microorillures et après une
fois que j'ai relevé mes défauts le
système me donne ma note donc là met un
gradard qui dans votre sauce interne
permettra ensuite de lui donner un état
et c'est exactement le même process au
niveau des ordinateurs ici un Mac ça
peut être un PC également là il y a
Marie Claire qui est en train de bosser
qui est en train de vérifier l'état de
l'écran qui regarde les boutons l'ESP et
esthétique et on va regarder si tout est
bien s'il y a des rayures des
microorayures si les boutons sont
écorchés ou pas et quand vous avez des
produits qui ne sont pas en état à être
revendu ou alors carrément qu'il y a
plus trop de marché parce que c'est des
vieux téléphones et qu'aujourd'hui ben
plus personne les veut et bien Smart va
les envoyer à des recycleurs agréés
français qui eux vont permettre
effectivementah de recycler alors le
boulot que fait Smart là voyez c'est une
caisse qu'on appellera de dépollution
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont enlever la
batterie et ensuite ils vont venir dans
une étape suivante les démanteler ils
mettront le verre avec le verre le
plastique avec le plastique et tout ce
qui va être puce électronique avec des
cartes électroniques comme ça tout part
tout est traité ici en France et c'est
un désengagement fort également de Smart
engagement pour l'environnement tout se
fait à circuit court même au niveau de
l'emploi et ça on en parle dans quelques
instants mais également ici au niveau du
recyclage parce que oui chez Smart on
veut faire attention à l'environnement
Smart avec 3A S a a a r t Smart une fois
qu'on connaî l'état de votre produit que
ce soit un smartphone ou que ce soit un
ordinateur parce que chez Smart bien
évidemment il y a tout et bien plus
encore et bien il est temps de venir le
réparer si besoin changer les parties
qui sont endommagées changer un bout
d'écran changer une batterie pourquoi
pas et puis même peut-être faire de la
soudure on va regarder si c'est possible
pour l'instant derrière ben il y a
pierre qui est en train de bosser et qui
est en train de changer un contour
d'écran qui lui par contre est
défectueux donc là ici on voit qu'on a
un contour d'écran qui était endommagé
qui a été changé donc là il y a du
double face qui a été mis tout autour
comme ça pour venir ensuite le reposer
et ensuite il va êtreosner ici comme ça
on voit que le contour est manquant bien
évidemment et hop comme par magie il va
arriver il va être clipsé et grâce à la
magie qui opère ici chez Smart et bien
on se retrouvera avec un contour d'écran
tout beau tout neuf donc là Grégor
explique-moi là tu es sur un un PC et il
faut venir changer une partie au niveau
du du clavier c'est ça voilà donc le
clavier en fait il est il est HS on voit
qu'il y a des touches qui manquent et il
y a des touches qui sont défectueuses
donc là donc je vais changer le clavier
donc sur ce modèle pour PIR changer le
clavier on est obligé de retirer la
carte mère pourir accès au clavier là tu
arrives par l'arrière du clavier en
faitoi voilà sur certains modèles le
clavier s'enlève par devant c'est plus
facile mais sur ce modèle là on est
obligé de passer par derrière passer
derrière donc toutes les vis on coulisse
le clavier je prends donc le clavier
tout neuf que je vais donc réinsérer
dans les rails donc après on va remettre
tout ce qui est pisse la plasturgie la
carte M ok génial donc là toi roman tu
es en train de bosser pour tu me disais
changer un écran sur un S20 S20 ultra 5G
ok S20 ultra 5G écran qui était
défectueux qui marchait pas c'est ça
testé chez vous donc là tu vas le
remplacer par quoi un nouvel écran qui
est ici ok alors comment ça se passe du
coup tu l'as enlevé ton écran déjà qui
était défectueux donc là on dévisse
toutes les plaques de protection avec
les vis après on sort les composants
comme la carte mère la batterie ainsi
que la carte F et puis après on
transfère tout ça sur le nouveau châssis
en revissant tout à sa place et donc
pour changer l'écran tu es obligé de
tout retirer pour pour avoir accès à
l'écran sur la face avant après tout à
fait ça c'est une plaque qui chauffe
c'est ça en fait c'est ça j'ai
température 91 deg je peux mettre le
Doig dessus qui est réglé
automatiquement par rapport à la chaleur
pour les téléphones d'accord donc là
effectivement ça va t'enlever tes colles
pour arriver récupérer ta batterie et la
mettre ok j'ai compris là ta batterie
elle a suffisamment enfin la colle en
tout cas suffisamment été mon
température et tuenlèves ok après on
essaie d'enlever tous les résidus ça ne
fasse pas une surépaisseur au moment du
collage et en fait on fait la même
opération c'estd que tout ce que tu as
démonté là-bas tu le remontes là et
après ton écran est changé c'est ça donc
là le smartphone allume c'est plutôt bon
signe donc là ça veut dire que tout est
bien recablé quand même c'est ça ça veut
dire que donc toi il y a un premier test
qui est fait sur ton poste qui est le
poste de de de réparation c'est ça mais
après il y aura un autre test qui sera
fait une fois que le smartphone sera
totalement fini prêt opérationnel pour
vérifier qu'il est fonctionnel c'est ça
dans l'intégralité on teste vraiment
tout après on a une application qui nous
permet de rien oublier un truc qui est
super intéressant c'est que la
réparation s'arrête pas uniquement à
changer une batterie ou changer un écran
ce qui est déjà énorme c'est qu'il
viennent même faire de la microdure
c'est-à-dire si par exemple il y a
besoin de venir changer un composant
extrêmement fin un micro ou un élément
sur la partie face ID et bien ici chez
Smart on peut venir le faire directement
et ça c'est quand même vachement bien
maintenant que not smartphone a été
réparé qu'on a changé ce qui avait à
changer la batterie l'écran que ça j'ai
encore ou qu'on a fait de la micro
sououdure et bien il est temps d'aller
voir Greg qui va venir tester les
dernières fonctionnalités pour être sûr
que tout marche alors Greg dis-moi hop
ici on vient vérifier que toutes les
réparations qui ont été faites
fonctionnent bien et que l'appareil est
fonctionnel est-ce que j'ai bien compris
exact en gros on va faire tous les mêmes
tests qu'au test d'entrée mais avec deux
trois petits trucs en plus pour bien
vérifier que la réparation a bien été
effectuée par exemple sur ce téléphone
on a la batterie qui a été changée faut
bien vérifier que tout a été bien remis
d'accord mais tu vas faire quoi tu vas
faire un test de charge complè tu vas la
recharger c'est c'est quoi le le le
process en fait je vais tester la charge
je testé que dans le téléphone la charge
a été bien mise on a une notre batterie
dans les iPhones yes la note ici qui est
bien à 100 % vu que la batterie éta
changé et toutit exactement tout est ce
que je vais faire aussi c'est que je
vais tester du coup comme je te disais
toutes les nappes qui ont été replacé
ouais le NFC pour le face ID beaucoup de
points fait de test d'entrée yes qu'on
vient refaire ici ça te permet
effectivement d'avoir une vision globale
et d'être sûr que le smartphone une fois
qu'il a quitté ton poste il est
totalement opérationnel et qu' y a pas
de problème et il se passe exactement la
même chose au niveau des PC c'est-à-dire
qu'on va tester les fonctionnalités voir
si la réparation est efficace et si tout
fonctionne bien et en plus de ça ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on vient ici
vous mettre comme on avait tout effacé
un Windows 10 avec licence si bien que
lorsque vous recevrez votre PC chez vous
vous n'avez plus qu'à l'allumer et à
l'utiliser très simplement et votre
ordinateur ensuite une fois qu'il est
beau fonctionnel et qui F fonction avec
sa licence et bien on vient le nettoyer
ici on vient enlever tous les petits
autocollants qui ont été mis même ceux
de son ancien propriétaire une fois
qu'il a été nettoyé qu'il a étéastiqué
qu'on lui a donné une note et bien
ensuite il a plus qu'à partir chez vous
pour arriver et être utilisé directement
et trouver son heureux propriétaire et
ça c'est quand même vachement bien sur
le site de spart vous verrez il y a
trois états esthétiques du plus bas au
meilleur ici c'est vraiment la dernière
notation d'un point de vue purement
esthétique puisque dans tous les cas on
s'assure que toutes les fonctionnalités
sont là et que votre smartphone sera
parfaitement fonctionnel de A à Z et
c'est ici que son on expédié vos
smartphones ils sont emballés avec soin
ils sont enlevés de leur petits papier
ils sont mis là-dedans reg des petites
boîes en carton ça c'est bien c'est
corresponsable bravo Smart et ils sont
emballés avec amour on met un petit
câble avec de recharge on met decvir
votre tiroir de carte SIM votre petite
pique pque j'ai toujours pas de N pour
ce cl et voilà ils partent une petite
caresse finale et il part directement à
leur heureux propriétaire et qu'est-ce
qui se passe si jamais votre produit a
une panne attention ça peut arriver
c'est là justement que la garantie Smart
arrive garanti 24 mois 24 mois sur les
smartphones 24 mois également sur les
ordinateurs 24 mois sur les tablettes
24is sur les monde bref garantie 24 mois
et 24 mois également sur votre batterie
c'est-à-dire que si dans les 24 mois
vous avez un problème avec votre
batterie et bien Smart s'engage à venir
intervenir très facilement et ce qui est
bien ici en plus de ça c'est qu'ils
interviennent normalement en 5 jours
vraé tout en sachant qu'en ce moment la
moyenne de l'entreprise c'est 2,5 jours
donc lorsque vous avez un problème vous
prenez votre téléphone allô Smart Smart
vous répond et ce que j'aime bien moi et
ce qui m'intéresse vraiment ici en plus
dans la démarche de l'entreprise c'est
que voyez ici on est au pied du pic loup
on est dans le sud de la France vous
avez la hline qui est là vous avez la
réparation qui est là-bas vous avez
l'expédition qui est là-bas bref tout
tout se fait ici au sein de cette même
usine et ils vont pas venir externaliser
la outline je ne sais où donc tout se
passe directement là avec de belles
garanties donc ça pour moi c'est
extrêmement rassurant et c'est également
une entreprise de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui va avoir des engagements
sociaux mais également environnementaux
et en plus de ça et ce qui est vachement
bien c'est que Smart c'est un centre de
formation qui travaille avec PUL emploi
pour ramener des gens près de l'emploi
des gens qui sont assez éloignés de
l'emploi ça peut être des demand
d'emploi en fin de droit bref ils
viennent former des gens ici avec 400
heures en tout ici de he en théorie 200
he en pratique et puis il y a à peu près
80 % des personnes qui sont formées ici
qui sont ensuite embauché directement
chez Smart et moi ce qui m'intéresse ici
c'est que Smart c'est entreprise qui a
des valeurs on le voit temps humaine
mais également aussi du point de vue de
l'environnement et n'oubliez pas pour
venir acheter vos produits en
reconditionné dans les meilleures
condition et bien Smart vous offre 15 €
des 200 € d'achat une fois de plus le
lien est juste en bas dans la
description vous savez maintenant qu'au
pied du pxin LOU en France pas très loin
de Montpellier on reconditionne les
produits avec amour et on le fait bien
que ce soit pour acheter un pc que ce
soit soit pour acheter un Mac que ce
soit pour acheter un smartphone un
iPhone ou encore sur Android une
tablette et des mondes connectés je vous
conseille vivement d'aller acheter vos
produits sur Smart je vous mets bien
évidemment le lien juste en bas dans la
description Smart avec 3A allez jeter un
œil parce qu'ici vous voyez on travaille
sérieusement on reconditionne
sérieusement il y a un SAV ici il y a
une hotline qui est ici tout ça se fait
un circuit court avec des valeurs que ce
soit pour l'emploi pour l'environnement
donc une fois de plus si vous voulez
acheter reconditionner venez chez Smart
vous le regretterez pas et d'ailleurs il
y a 2 ans on était déjà venu ici on
avait fait une première vidéo où on
avait les équipes de Smart et visiter si
vous voulez la découvrir et bien Z juste
là ans on avait des masques c'était déjà
très très bien à
l'époque